justement madjide guerrab député de la
9e circonscription des français établis
hors de france et en direct avec nous
sur arte france
bonjour majid el guerrab vous êtes un
ex-député lrm rattaché désormais à
l'union des démocrates radicaux et
libéraux
vous représentez les français établis au
maghreb également en afrique de l'ouest
comment est ce que vous avez réagi en
apprenant ce dérapage l'afrique pointait
du doigt alors qu'on semble
précautionneux rang en europe
je crois que comme beaucoup de personnes
qui ont réagi sur les réseaux sociaux
dans les médias j'ai eu pas mal de
tribunes
j'ai plein de collègues parlementaires
qu'ils ont réagi assez vivement
on a tous été choqués choquée d'avoir un
échange un peu hors du temps
une discussion un peu qui était au début
très sérieuse et qui petit à petit
arrive à une forme de provocation et
d'ailleurs ça a même été dit sans
vouloir provoquer et c'est quand on veut
provoquer ça suscite forcément la
provocation
et puis les gens se sentent provoquer
donc les gens ont réagi
et puis je veux le dire un peu de
manière assez y est assez forte
ce n'est pas les africaines et les
africains quand est le premier à être
choqués sont d'abord les françaises et
les français les européens qui vivent en
afrique quand on entend ce type de
propos de discussion de on va tester de
manière un peu plus massive sur les
populations africaines parce qu'elles
sont plus à risque etc
dans une discussion qui se voulait un
peu des changes
rigoureux et scientifique on a tous été
choqués je prends note
je prends note que les différentes
personnes continue ses propos se sont un
peu après excusez que la chaîne et les
différentes structures dans lesquelles
ils évoluent se sont excusés les chefs
d'état africains ont eu un entretien
avec le président de la république donc
ça dépasse simplement un échange bon
enfant entre entre deux scientifiques
justement vous parlez d'excusés ils se
sont donc excusé faute à demi pardonnée
ou bien ce que vous attendez une
sanction exemplaire qu'est ce que vous
attendez de la justice moi à titre
personnel et je crois que il serait
malvenu de vouloir dans cette période de
crise sanitaire vouloir s'acharner sur
telle ou telle personne notamment des
médecins ou des chercheurs non là ce que
je voudrais qu'on mette une bonne fois
pour toutes qui soit dit clairement
c'est est ce que ce type de propos dans
une chaîne de grande information une
chaîne avec avec une grande écoute
est ce que ce type de propos peuvent
être tenus et s'ils ne peuvent pas
l'être ils doivent être condamnés donc
je n'ai pas porté plainte
et donc c'est ce que je veux vraiment
dire aux uns et aux autres c'est que je
n'ai pas porté plainte
j'ai simplement saisi le procureur de la
république pour lui signaler
selon l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénale que des propos qui me semblent
injurieux qui me semblent avoir un
caractère discriminatoire raciste ont
été tenus est ce que c'est le cas et en
procureur et à la justice de de
poursuivre non mais qu'est ce que vous
attendez vous nous à titre personnel et
jeu quand je dis nous je parle des
françaises et des français qui vivent en
afrique
le représentant et je veux vraiment
saluer tous les conseillers consulaires
leurs élus locaux et veulent une
réaction une réaction officielle de la
part de
justice et qui est évidemment que de
tels propos ne soutiennent plus jamais
sur nos ondes
et maintenant plutôt que de réagir de
manière un peu comment dire sporadiques
à chaque fois que ce type de propos est
tenue on le signale à la justice et la
justice s'en saisit en disant si c'est
propos sont racistes ou pas moi je pense
qu'ils le sont et c'est pour ça que j'ai
saisi le procureur de la justice et donc
j'attends bien évidemment une
condamnation sos racisme a saisi le csa
on a entendu parler en a peur at on
entendu parler de cette affaire dans les
médias
comment est-ce que vous expliquer ce
silence médiatique
je pense que à l'égard des africaines et
des africains il ya une forme de
légèreté de légèreté d'ailleurs vous
voyez dans la séquence quand on regarde
la séquence dans sa globalité
au départ on parle de manière très
sérieuse et puis tout un goût on lance
comme ça de manière provocante l'afrique
en disant voilà on n'a qu'à faire des
essais grandeur nature et puis on verra
si ça marche ça marche pas non quand on
parle des africaines des africains et
c'est un peu dans cet esprit d'ailleurs
que nouvelle génération de femmes et
d'hommes politiques ont été élus c'est
pour dire qu'aujourd'hui nous voulons
une nouvelle relation avec l'afrique et
c'est aussi pour marquer symboliquement
que n'accepterons plus ce type de propos
que ce type de propos soient tenus
voilà vous on le répète à vous
représenter les français établis au
maghreb et en afrique de l'ouest vous
avez dit que les propos ont choqué ses
personnages que vous avez eue par
téléphone d
des personnes justement des français
établis en afrique que vous ont-elles
dit exactement quels ont été leurs
réactions
j'ai une représentant dans les
différents postes diplomate diplomatique
dans les consulats etc
j'ai eu les conseiller consulaire donc
c'est pour celles et ceux qui ne le
savent pas ce sont les élus des français
de l'étranger avec lesquels je discute
sur toute ma circonscription que ce soit
au maghreb ou en afrique de l'ouest et
ils sont tous ou très choqués et je vous
avoue que ce type de propos n'êtes pas
la france voilà et nous les françaises
et les français qui vivent en afrique ne
peuvent plus tolérer ce genre de propos
et je vous le redis c'est eux qui sont
choqués avant que l'information est que
les peuples africains se soulève et
c'est nous-mêmes français qui vivent en
afrique sommes outrés et donc c'est en
leur nom aussi que je saisi le procureur
de la justice merci madjid el guerrab
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes député ex
la république en mars désormais affilié
à l'union à des démocrates radicaux et
libéraux député de la 9e circonscription
des français établis hors de france